sabías que seguimos utilizando algunos
números antiguos y lo hacemos más
seguido de lo que crees en un juego por
puntos en donde se va llevando el
marcador
yo voy anotando los puntos en una tabla
como esta y cada que alguien anota un
punto agregó una línea pues justo así es
que los antiguos egipcios escribían los
números aunque sólo del 1 al 9 para el
10 y para los números más grandes tenían
otros símbolos utilizamos líneas o varas
como las llamaban los egipcios para ir
llevando cuentas de uno en uno porque es
más sencillo ir agregando elementos que
borrar el número y escribirlo otra vez
con el marcador que tenemos ahora si el
equipo 2 anota otro punto en la
numeración egipcia se coloca otra vara
en la nuestra que es la numeración
decimal se borraría el número y se
escribiría el que sigue
esto es con números pequeños pero para
números más grandes no era muy práctico
anotar 324 varas imagina cómo estarían
sus cuadernos de matemáticas o más bien
sus paredes de matemáticas porque los
egipcios se escribían en paredes en
piedra y algunos lo hacían en papiros
para el número como el 324 no escribían
las 324 varas ya que tenían un símbolo
diferente para cada múltiplo de 10 es
decir que para el 1 tenían un símbolo
para el 10 tenían otro para el 100 otro
para el 1000 otro y así sucesivamente el
símbolo del 1 es la vara que ya
conocemos y que seguimos usando ojalá no
quieran cobrar por derechos de autor
para el 10 usaban un símbolo llamado
arco o talón que es más o menos así el
cielo representaban con una cuerda que
podía ir enrollada hacia la derecha o
hacia la izquierda para el 1000 dibujaba
en una flor como ésta
el 10.000 le escribían con un dedo el
cien mil era un pez la verdad es que a
veces parece un peso otras un renacuajo
y en algunas representaciones tienen
hasta una rana para un millón o lo que
representaba el infinito al ser un
número muy grande usaban el dibujo de un
ser humano asustado o hincado
la variación en algunos símbolos es
porque no siempre los escribimos igual e
incluso en el sistema decimal hay
variaciones hay quienes escriben el 7
así otros le ponen una línea en medio
hay personas que ponen el 1 como una
raya y otras le ponen una línea pequeña
arriba o abajo así que es normal que los
egipcios fueran cambiando un poco sus
símbolos con el paso de los años pero no
todos los números son múltiplos de 10
para armar un número lo que hacían era
repetir el símbolo correspondiente por
ejemplo si vamos a escribir el 324
pondríamos tres cuerdas enrollada porque
el 3 está en el lugar de las centenas y
representa 300 al dibujar tres cuerdas
son tres de 100 y tenemos 300
dos arcos con valor de 10 cada uno para
el 2 que representa dos decenas y cuatro
varas para las cuatro unidades
si te fijas ocupa más espacio que la
numeración decimal pero en casos en los
que su numeración ocupa menos espacio
que la nuestra como en un millón que con
solo un símbolo ya lo escribimos y en
decimal necesitamos siete dígitos la
mayoría de las veces la numeración
egipcia es más tardada y ocupa mucho más
espacio es por eso que a lo largo de los
años la numeración decimal fue más
popular otro factor es que en el sistema
egipcio no hay ceros imagina que haces
la resta 5.400 menos 5400 de numeración
egipcia en la numeración decimal podemos
poner el 0 sin problema pero los
egipcios no tienen un símbolo para el 0
te imaginas las confusiones que habría
también el hecho de que no importa el
orden en que se acomodan los símbolos en
algunas ocasiones resulta confuso para
los que no somos egipcios si ponemos
estos símbolos equivalen al mismo número
aunque están revueltos
los dos representan el 258 porque
tenemos dos símbolos de 100 45 de 10 y 8
de 1
en el sistema decimal si colocamos los
números revueltos cambia por completo el
valor no es lo mismo 258 que 582 debemos
admitir que la numeración egipcia es más
variada y si consideramos que escribían
con jeroglíficos o sea los dibujos que
todos conocían es normal que sus números
también fueran hechos con dibujos la
siguiente vez que lleves una cuenta con
barras y ya lleves 9 podrías usar un
arco para representar el 10 solo no
olvides que la calculadora no entiende
de arcos renacuajos y dedos